this week on world stories and
insecticide and dead bees in Romania a
courageous stand against Christian
terror in Uganda but we start with a man
who's concerned about the consequences
of the recent elections in Germany due
to the arrival of the radical right-wing
AFD party in Parliament as a Holocaust
survivor he finds it unbearable deficit
stmas I didn't touch to me off guard
fascism in Germany never went away it
just took on a new form
[Music]
[Applause]
B&C we will hound this government we
will hunt down Chancellor Merkel
or whomever else we need to we will take
back our country and our people what
does he want them the borders from 1939
again horse Zellweger clearly remembers
the beginning of Nazi rule in Germany at
school in Berlin he was verbally abused
and beaten up by his classmates it
started with him calling me horrible
names like smart-aleck Jew or Jewish Pig
it got worse and worse more offensive
and then deadly yeah in my 261 members
of xebaz extended family were murdered
in the Holocaust fascism and Germany's
coming to terms with its Nazi past our
core issues in his life and after seeing
so much in his ninety years he's
horrified by Sunday's German election
result he's been sharing his reactions
online to be honest I don't understand
the astonishment and anger that the AFD
has made it into Parliament Nazis have
been in Parliament since 1949 they had
Nazi ministers one was even Chancellor
[Music]
Kurt your key zinger was Chancellor from
1966 to 69 former Nazi Party members
held seats in the West German parliament
until the 1980s across most of the
political spectrum
Horst zelicah sees the rise of the AFD
as a continuation of this tradition I
just hope that a real change of thinking
happens here
and that this long-standing refusal to
take the far-right seriously will
finally be confronted we have to expose
this ugly extremism and I hope this
confrontation will play out in the new
German parliament nation does the I
don't want to see the AFD takeover on
the contrary
[Music]
in Romania beekeepers are facing
disaster bee colonies there are dying
off
they say the use of a long banned
insecticide is behind it millions of
bees used to bus around here collecting
nectar but two years ago all the buzzing
activity around beekeeper cost Elgar
Salah fell silent let's take a look all
the bees are dead all because of this
chemical they sprayed on the fields my
entire business is destroyed at some
point I'll have to burn down everything
in the spring of 2015
wheat fields here were sprayed with the
insecticide 5 percent which contains the
chemical fiber nil known for killing
ticks it's used near domestic animals
was already banned at that time Grolsch
olive says that people in the village of
preached in one of eastern Romania's
poorest regions weren't even informed it
was a disaster for us beekeepers we were
robbed of our livelihood
a beekeeper can't exist that bees these
gentlemen caused an ecological disaster
here they didn't think about the people
or the animals or even about us oh
they're interested in is money and they
can't get enough of it Grushenka lost 24
beehives and with them his livelihood
the same happened to other beekeepers
along with farming honey was one of the
few sources of income for people and
preached the beekeepers are suing this
man exterminator Constantine three goats
for using banned chemicals he sprayed
the fibers it and now he presents it to
us with a clear conscience he no longer
sells it but he does still sell similar
agents the evidence shows that I'm
innocent
everything was signed and permitted I
was supposed to exterminate ticks they
live in the fields not on airplanes or
ships so that's where I sprayed I'm not
to blame
the beekeepers disagree contaminated
eggs in Belgium and Holland have focused
attention on dangers of the insecticide
5% which contains the dangerous chemical
fiber no the beekeepers want to put
pressure on the manufacturer who is
located in Bucharest the company ignored
interview requests but this invoice
shows that it delivered 5% to animal
breeders slowly but surely nature seems
to be recovering
Costel growl ah makes a discovery wild
bees have moved into one of his hives
that encourages him to begin keeping
bees again but it will be a long time
before he can once again make a living
from it
[Music]
for years a civil war between a
Christian terrorist group and government
forces has been raging in Uganda one
brave man is trying to heal the victims
wounds st. Joseph's Hospital in Kitgum
northern Uganda here some 200 patients
are receiving treatment of the wounds
they sustained during the Lord's
Resistance Army insurgency millions were
massacred mutilated tortured enslaved
and raped in the conflict between the
LRA and government troops Victor Rochon
and his organization African Youth
Initiative network provides support for
victims who until now have never seen a
doctor such as Amara dreams O'Mara James
was abducted from a BIA and he spent
about seven months in captivity so while
he was in captivity would be made to
walk long distance but then as a process
of torture the the rebel kept on
piercing his leg with the bionics I have
no problem with forgiving those who
injured me as long as I'm healed it
depends on my ability to become normal
again that defines whether or not I can
forgive come on Betty come dig Araucana
copra pay Amara James will walk again
Victor uses these success stories to
convince the UN and the European Union
to fund his project he grew up in the
midst of the violence and later worked
as a journalist and reported from the
conflict zone
ten years ago Viktor quit his radio job
to fully commit to his organization many
victims have not forgotten what happened
to them how can you make peace tangible
to people who have suffered injustice
and that's why we say heal people
physical injuries help them heal
emotionally it'll hop in the space for
historical dialogue a difficult dialogue
the dialogue that might be going through
layers and unveiling many untold painful
stories in 2015 Viktor was nominated for
the Nobel Peace Prize since then he has
turned down prestigious job offers
abroad because he knows that Uganda's
wounds are still a long way from being
healed
[Music]
our last report is about a machine
that's facing extinction it's only still
used in a few countries such as India
it's the typewriter
[Music]
the sound of a long-forgotten
era outside a local court in Delhi
street-type is still earn a living from
a machine that's obsolete in most parts
of the world Raj Bala has been working
at this exact spot since 1988 punching
out affidavits sales contracts rent
agreements and other legal documents on
a secondhand machine she makes about
five to six dollars a day just enough to
make ends meet manual typewriters are
really heavy they can't get damaged we
don't have to worry about electricity
failures we don't need a printer or
cables all we need is a machine and
table that's it Raj father says typing
is the only work she's ever trained for
and she's not giving it up anytime soon
I love this typewriter like my own child
it's my only source of income I continue
typing till the very end but the end has
arrived for this iconic machine and
typing has also become a dying skill as
India pushes to modernize and digitize
its economy there are ever fewer takers
for the antiquated technology 80
typewriter stand upside down as a result
shops like Rajesh mulches are on the
decline his family has been selling
typewriters since the 1930s in Delhi
faced with stiff competition from
computers pulta has been forced to
reinvent his business restoring antique
typewriters like these quite some time I
was feeling depressed and I was actually
seeing the end of the trade
but as most of the dealers dealing in
typewriters packed up somehow I remained
because of my passion and that is making
some business sense the typewriter
Mitra survived in the hands of skillful
payment giving the old machines a
much-needed tuna
perhaps destined for a collector shell
or as an exhibit in a museum
[Music]
you